George is in Georgia hi George how are
you George did I do something wrong Zack
Georgia Lucas I'm sorry I got John mute
I'm sorry okay I'd rather not be on mute
how can I help
yo I do freelance programming and for
the past year so I've been working for a
client and I was paid on time every time
we thought the project would take a
certain amount of time the time went
over the budget went over I received
very few requirements so live that I had
to make it up on my own get clearance
from him that things were good the
client is in possession of 100% of the
code of 90% of the work is complete I've
signed over all accounts we had cloud
accounts manager he's in full full
possession and ownership for those and
now the client wants a refund a complete
refund even I think a little more than
what I was paid I don't feel like my
fund what what why does he want a refund
yeah I don't know he's upset with me why
and he's turned it over to collections
because we went over time and money I
mean he was there when that happened I
know this wasn't like no a sudden event
every year every month he wrote the
check and continued the deal yes okay so
now it knows thing does the code not
does the code not work the code is only
about 90 percent complete but it works
on or percent of what's there works just
fine
and someone else could finish it
since he has effectively fired you yeah
he's already hired another team you told
me okay um but it's in collections he
took it over to collections I got a
letter from a collector or Evan I
answered yes for validation they haven't
responded yet in over 30 days yeah I
watch
money is involved he watched 30 I think
it came in at about like $25,000 yes sir
yeah get an attorney okay cousin you
know you know you know you know not yet
you're not presenting anything here to
me that sounds like he that he has a
moral or a legal case that's you know
the morality of it that's something that
really occurred to me and I talked my
wife about it and some friends and I
said you know I said legally there's
there's nothing I said but morally
should I do this and they said no you
did a good job for him you'll stand I
Val warranty my work I stand behind it I
told him I would help him well it was an
incremental acceptance every incremental
acceptance every month it wasn't like
you presented him with a completed
project or semi completed project with a
25,000 dollar bill and you presented
that to him six months late
he was incremental II month by month
involved in receiving the code and
paying the bill and agreeing to the
calendar and the prices overruns yeah
yeah yeah then you got no moral
obligation George here's the thing
you're wrestling with my friend and I
really want to help you with this you're
trying to make sense of something that's
nonsensical you're trying to rationalize
why on earth would this person be crazy
silly and stupid and I don't want you to
waste the energy going down that path
he may have Corona brain well but he's
not nice that's the thing or he's
bipolar something's wrong but I but but
don't don't let it take up any more of
your headspace as they've said I'd reach
out to an attorney
have a conversation do you if you can't
have a conversation with a guy on
talking about of the tree have you tried
that oh yeah I've wrote him a couple
emails and he's he's nice he wrote back
he said but you'll have to declare
bankruptcy to get out of it no you will
okay so I mean that you know now you've
gone to threaten and make a bad move bad
move oh yeah you need to get an attorney
and you need to slap a cease and desist
on him
and you need to have that attorney slap
that collection agency in the next week
they got no basis to collect a bill here
because there's not a build you but you
could turn him into collections I mean
they're the same thing because he didn't
finish the project with you and you were
under contract to do that so now hey
listen if we screw up around here and we
do sometimes screw up we are insert our
ribbon I mean however in that case we
own it right and we write the check
immediately but threaten me oh now we'll
go a whole nother way that that cost you
can threaten the hillbilly not a good
plan